hello everyone the world was struck with
some extremely sad news yesterday after
eleven Ahriman published this on his
Twitter feed there we have it xi says I
have no words to express the grievance
over my wife our Ian's death she was
intelligent hardworking and joyous
person that lived a beautiful life so
extremely sad news I don't know if if
you were following what's going on some
two weeks ago she had a car accident in
Yerevan and she was in intensive care
since then but yesterday as you see here
we received the news that she passed
away so extremely said I can only
imagine how eleven feels it's it it's
just terrible is gonna take a lot of
time to get out of this she was very
young they would they were basically
newly Wed I think they were married in
2000 2018 or 2017 so really just
terrible I thought I was she is also a
chess player I thought that we would
tribute her by showing a very nice game
and I didn't even get get a chance to
search for games and already a lot of
you suggest that some of the games and
this is one of the games that was
suggested to me that I really enjoyed
against the Norwegian Grandmaster
Benjamin are wall and not kovitch
although he wasn't a grandmaster at the
time this game was played still a very
strong player it was played in a 2012 in
the London a London chest open and it's
really just a just a remarkable
attacking game so without further ado
let's let's check it out Arion opens the
width d4 we have f5 not which goes for
the for the Dutch defense we have Knight
to f3 Knight to f6 and now c4 and here
not which starts at create the the
Stonewall setup of the Dutch we have
Knight to c3 and d5 now Bishop to F for
continuing development and now c6 and
the the Stonewall setup has been
completed we have III preparing to
develop the lights work the ship and a
Bishop to e7 also black to pierce the
castle we have h3 taking away the g4
Square from from blacks pieces and now
Knight to e4 just landing that night
in the center of the board it is an
excellent out was and Arion does the
same we have Knight to e5 and here our
black just castles and there is one game
in the database where where h4 was
played but Arion goes for Bishop to d3
and it is as of move nine that we have a
completely new game so black continues
development b6 prepares the vignette to
the light square bishop we have castles
by Orion and Bishop the b7 and here
Bishop captures on e4 asking black what
do you do want to do here how will you
recapture D captors on e4 is the safer
choice then white develops the queen
gets the rook into the game ended the
game continues however however black
tried a more aggressive approach with F
captures on e4 opening up the F file for
his rook but it also gives a white a bit
more room to to start an attack and be
more aggressive so Queen to g4 already a
very very active square for the Queen
with the threat of just Queen captures
on e6 so look the f5 blocking the
Queen's attack to the e6 pawn and now f3
preparing to capture win the pawn and
just open up at the file for the rook so
e captures on f3 we have rook captures
on f3 and now it's not it's not all that
easy for black to find a move for
example if d captures and c4 seems very
reasonable you're you're preparing c5 to
open up this diagonal then Bishop to h6
is just winning for white as you're
threatening mate and also you're
preparing to capture here so once you
defend this Bishop to f8 you just bring
the knight into the game
and it's it's an overwhelming position
black cannot hold this none of black's
pieces are really doing anything if c5
opening up this diagonal doesn't really
matter
rook captures it captures Queen captures
and you're losing the game whatever you
play here it's not extremely hard to
find a move but the most straightforward
if you capture then you run into a queen
g4 checking a chat and Knight f7 mate or
if King goes does not go to hid if you
block with the bishop then it's Queen
the e6 check King here you pick up the
Queen
nothing to it check here check and this
will just be a nice swift mate
so after root chakras on f3 you don't
really have the option of a slow move
you have to bring more defenders into
the game Knight to d7 here note which
says that the same idea of the shift h6
no longer applies because at the end of
that line
for example Bishop their fate let's say
you bring Knight into the game or
something but you don't have the option
of having anything like this because the
knight just grabs the night and if
anything it will be black was better so
instead after rook captures on f3 we
have Knight to d7 like we said and now
rook the g3 already threatening mate and
g7 Bishop the f8 blocking and now Knight
captures on d7 freeing the e5 square for
the bishop so you will be able to bring
another piece into the attack Queen
captures and Bishop to e5 check
and so as okay the the g7 square is
defended three times so black has black
has some time to start developing so he
goes c5 he wants to open up this Bishop
diagonal the problem is with with this
move C characters on d5 now he has to
decide how he's going to recapture of
course he doesn't want to capture with
the bishop so he captures with the pawn
but the problem is now the Queen is
undefended and now rook to f3 and you
cannot capture because you hang the
Queen so rook to f7 now opening up a
discovery on the Queen and also the roof
is now defending the Queen but now not
trading but instead rook captures on f7
saying that if you capture my Queen now
I first grab your Bishop which check and
only then pick up the Queen and at the
end of this line I'm just up a whole
piece so instead after rook captures on
f7 Queen captures on f7 was played and
now rook to f1 Arion brings the last
rook into the game and as you can see
white's pieces are a lot more active
this bishopman rook for the moment not
doing all that much we have Queen to g6
offering a trade of Queens but now Queen
to d7 r e maneuvering the Queen with an
attack on the bishop on b7 Bishop the c6
attacking the Queen and Queen to c7 now
and now finally black has black has a
moment to catch his breath
so rook to e8 preparing to kick away the
Queen
away from the board would look to e7 but
now another excellent attacking idea
rook to f3 saying that ok this rook can
now come to g3 and then we add even more
pieces to the attack and also you can
can't move the Queen away from the
defense of the f7 square so here there
are a lot of things you can try but for
example rook the e7 is not one of them
because rook to e7 now runs into just
rook captures and I fade with check King
captures and Bishop d6 just threatening
to win more material this is now this is
gonna fall and this is gonna fall so
Queen e6 you have to defend the room
just captures here and again now you
have to two pieces for a rock but at any
point you can just pick off that rook
and then you're just gonna be up a piece
so easy game so after rook to f3 not
which played b5 instead he says okay I'm
defending gg7 several times so it's not
a problem I wanna I wanna continue
pushing would be for c4 and so on but
this only helps white as a white the
knight is basically the only piece
that's not included in the attack so
here Knight to e2 as a great person once
said the hardest move to find is with
the knight back some nights the e2
preparing to bring the knight into the
game with Knight f4 but black continues
pushing c4 but he wants to go
b4 c3 and create a passed pawn however
Knight to f4 now comes with an attack on
the Queen okay Queen h6 nothing really
happening here these six square is
covered twice by the Queen and by the
rook however here comes Knight to h5 and
we reach the position from the thumbnail
well almost
here the problem is if you capture the
night with the Queen Queen captures here
and now you run into rook captures and
f8 and now it doesn't matter Queen
captures or King
rocket race or King capture screen
captures and g7 will be made so the
night is is off-limits here you cannot
capture it so rook to e7 was played and
now we reach the position from the
thumbnail where both the Queen is under
attack ended the night here and now it's
your move
feel free to pause the video and finish
this brilliant attacking game out while
I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finishing this
spectacular attack and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
it's not rook captures nf8 as if you
were thinking about that move again
because here after King captures you
don't have Bishop to d6 because now
Queen captures on e3 comes with check
you also defend this and after the King
moves and now you move the bishop and
you no longer white no longer wins a
piece here so here nothing really
happens you defend it successfully at
some point you might try something like
95% g7 but black will just ignore your
Bishop g6 and you don't really have a
better move other than trading here and
you just trade down into well not right
away obviously first we're gonna get the
knight out of the way check King moves
and now we capture that character's
captors Knight c7 B 4 and so on but it's
black who's definitely better here
however if after roof d7 you found the
immediate Bishop to b6 then
congratulations you have found the truth
behind the position point is the game
can easily be surrendered here as if the
Queen is captured and just route
characters and f8 is made so you have to
try something else but there is nothing
else even if you try something like
Queen characters on e3 to get the rook
away from f8 character's captures still
after Bishop captures here again you're
just up up a full rook and completely
unplayable so instead after Bishop to b6
and not which tried one more idea Queen
to e6 but now yes you would you've
defended the rook but now the problem is
just Bishop captures on e7 and this is
what our en played and it was in this
position that Benjamin are rolling out
which resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here point is if
you capture with the Queen you lose the
bishop so that's pretty much
self-explanatory white is just up a
whole rook and if you don't if you
capture with the bishop
well then you run into Queen b8 check
and there's no good defense however you
defend you either get made it or you
lose material your only defense is
Bishop to d8 which frees the e8 Square
for the Queen but still just Queen
captures and after Queen e8 you can just
capture capture and go back and you are
again up a whole room completely winning
so after Bishop captures any seven not
which resigned and this beautiful
beautiful game was created it's it's
just a shame that it was the game was
not resigned after Bishop to d6 just to
have a to have a to have a greater
ending position but okay you know
sometimes you have to try a queen e6 and
then just captures and that was it
so that's the game really really
impressive game bye-bye aria who is she
had an interest she has a title of a
woman's international master so also
enjoyed chest very much she she spoke
several languages fluently and she was
standing up for for her PhD in in
Russian foreign Russian policy so really
a lot of hobbies a lot of interests and
it's just a shame at 33 years of age so
young at that to go with a car accident
so like I said I will put a link to
lemons tweet in the description below it
will be the first thing you will see so
in case you want to extend your
condolences and yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank matheus Jakob Dario Jankovic
Andrew peri-urban wolf and alexander
afanasyevitch into my channel thank you
a lot I really appreciate it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
I'm thinking for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the Morphy saga and checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and for
the end of this video we're just gonna
show this nice photo of Lebanon Aryan
from their wedding day for for some 10
seconds and and that's it for this video
I will see you soon guys